hoje eu vou-vos explicar o segredo para
vocês conseguirem marcar um golo destes
uf não acredito sai o remate de longe a
bola
[Aplausos]
do laço mas antes vamos tomar a pequena
música o caso
fácil
eh
crédito chocolate
D aos meus favoritos Cássio também são
os meus Então vamos comer dois
familla falou tá sempre em Casa Favorita
chocolate crocantes e deliciosos basta
porque mas não é bué cremosinho mano
creminho esta é Acredite
caso agora desaparece daqui que eu tenho
um vídeo para fazer vai-te embora
agora é tu meu qual é que é o
segredo Afinal Dark como é que Tu
conseguiste marcar aquele golaço do meio
campo pessoal eu só tentei a minha sorte
eu rematei com toda a minha força ali do
meio-camp Man como podem ver o caí
trocinho todo estão aqui a ver o slow
motion eu parti-me toda arrematar aquela
bola mas no final concretizamos o golo
pessoal fiquei muito contente de ter
sido o primeiro a marcar ali naquele
jogo e ser um golaço deste de Jander Mas
acima de tudo foi muita sorte e eu
acabei por nem ver o golo porque quando
eu olhei para a bola aqui neste momento
eu vi que a bola já estava muito para
cima Então caí no chão já meio triste
mas quando eu comecei a ouvir as pessoas
a gritar ei entra na minha cabeça Ok a
bola entrou como é que é possível a bola
ter entrado com uma distância destas
então ya nem eu estava à espera Nem os
meus companheiros de jogo estavam à
espera e foi um sucesso a bola acabou
por entrar eu fiquei muito feliz por ter
sido o primeiro a abrir ali o marcador
para a minha equipa YouTubers mas
pessoal e essencialmente Este vídeo é
para vos dizer muito obrigado a quem foi
lá no estádio a quem a quem acompanhou
de perto a quem ajudou esta causa nós
conseguimos arrecadar mais de 19.000 €
para a associação acreditar o que é
muito muito bom portanto certamente que
vão acontecer próximos eventos fiquem
atentos e parabéns também é o movimento
de por ter organizado aqui este evento e
acima de tudo pessoal Este vídeo é para
vos mostrar todos os Highlights os meus
Highlights Neste jogo eu chutei eu
marquei Ah eu defendi portanto estão
aqui os Highlights todos se quiserem ver
assim mais de perto e mais outro detalhe
bem cortadinho e é isso malta Espero que
gostem aqui deste vídeo fiquem bem e até
já
tá tranquilo a jogar a bola lá mais na
frente dá
Linha de Passe bola regressa não
acredito saiu
[Aplausos]
na frente do marcador e é um golaço com
direito a polimento não necessariamente
remata do meio da pista e eu nem tinha
medo do Torres que é um homem grande mas
a bola passou por cima da Torres Dark
frame que tinha acabado de entrada Isto
é que se chama o entrar ver e vencer uma
mensagem subliminar para para o novo
Mind porque os streamers têm treinador e
estão agora a perder Portanto ele vai
ter que mexer na equipa ele vai ter que
fazer alguma coisa e eu acho que já está
ali dentro preparado só por causa das
coisas então atenção
[Risadas]
Miguel Alves quase dominava não
conseguiu
pega na bola será revira volta ele diz
aonde vem mas demora um bocado atenção
ao passe junto bate aí
uai Miguel Alves em cima da linha
Foi bonzinho
[Aplausos]
para dentro da grande área Afonso
Figueiredo
está feito
quem quer ganhar espírito manda a bola
para o campo não estão por dentro dos
jogadores em cima
[Aplausos]
está muita virada
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muitos doces para aqui é o teu lado
dançar
Exatamente é tudo
junto
[Aplausos]
ali há pouco no penalti eu não sei o que
é que vocês acham mas eu não se esforçou
muito digamos que foi consensual com
tudo que nós queremos ver
e marcar aquele até poderia dizer
antes de marcar tinha dedicado portanto
não vamos fazer essa receita podemos
dizer que o Dark frame marcou o melhor
Golem e vier portanto Será que já temos
novo homem
para já é um grande candidato
mas bem defendido muito bem defendido
por centri com a bola a chegar novamente
segunda da segunda parte alguém tira
Dark frame do YouTube e Coloque numa
equipa de futebol
[Aplausos]
Ai Jesus
como é que é possível
dar eu não sei se as pessoas do passe de
Ferreira estão a ver esta exibição de
arco mas ah
eu acho eu acho
o passo de feira
olha olha
não por cima
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ainda sonho ainda esperança a equipa dos
YouTubers ainda pode sair daqui com o
troféu em 3D e confete vamos lá então
Fisio Roque falhar o jogo
marca defende não tá
ficas ali e continua
Mas isso acontece atenção
Henrique imensa desculpa peço imensa
desculpa Henrique o que interessa Sem
dúvida nenhuma é a acreditar é ajudar a
acreditar mas a vitória Essa vai para a
equipa de vermelho vai para os YouTubers
uma grande salva de palmas para os
youtuber de uma grande salva de palmas
também para os vencidos para o streamers
Uma salva de palmas também para as
árbitros Uma salva de palmas para todo
este público foi até aqui à capital de
móvel Uma salva de palmas para vocês
tiverem em casa a acompanhar-nos uma
salva de palmas 3.000 pessoas que
compraram bilhete que deslocaram num
domingo de muito calor desde a família e
chegaram aqui do lado esquerdo tá tá tá
tá
atrás de mim
vem o homem do jogo com a taça vem logo
vem o homem do jogo com a taça eleito
eleito pela equipa SporTV como homens
então com essa taça e ah realmente o MTS
disse tudo
foi um evento incrível e muito trabalho
a organizar isto Estou muito orgulhoso
dele e por isso eu quero doar esta taça
ao movimento
[Aplausos]
queria também chamar aqui à senhora que
eu acho que ela está a vir aqui
[Aplausos]
a acreditar isto é uma taça que fez
e acabou aguardar
[Aplausos]
e pronto
obrigada por todo mundo obrigado
obrigado
estar em casa atrás do computador a
criar conteúdos e decidiram vir aqui
colocar uma posição
só um jogador aqui e chegamos ao fim do
vídeo Pessoal espero que tenham gostado
deixem muito like aqui no vídeo porque
isso ajuda imensa partilhar comentem aí
qual para vocês foi o melhor jogador em
campo e tudo mais se vocês foram ao
estado eles ficaram em casa a ver a Live
do mundo comentem isso tudo aí embaixo
pessoal eu quero ver a vossa opinião e é
isso malta fiquem bem até a próxima